here's a
terrible gigantic question that you and
i have been talking about an awful lot
and we're not going to spend much time
on right now but i think it's worth
saying and
from it's from someone who asks us who
who we see a lot here um and just say
uh you don't even know what the topic is
yet but i will say um
we
will be coming back to this a fair bit
but um
it's a terrible question
what's the deal with the left and
pedophilia
from pro-pedo articles to
maps that's a acronym standing for minor
attracted person which is a euphemism
cover-ups
apologia i never know how to pronounce
that word etc it's an alarming
correlation
furthermore i predict trans and
non-binary will soon be eclipsed by a
push for its pedophilia's acceptance
yeah
yeah so this is a complete disaster yes
those who have predicted
that this would arise have been correct
the scope of it is
quite scary and maybe most scary of all
is the fact that this is now as the
question implies being taken seriously
yeah so people think they're being like
inclusive or something
to no i don't i don't think i don't
that's sort of i think i think i've seen
that in some of the sort of the
so-called intelligentsia
on the left but there's a question about
what it means that they think they're
being inclusive i don't think they're
being inclusive i don't think they think
they're being inclusive i think they're
being bullied into accepting it because
they will be stigmatized as
non-inclusive if they don't okay well i
think that's the same thing but i get
your distinction um that they don't they
can't quite put their finger on why
you know why it's not a free speech
issue or something and so they say well
maybe it's just a
sexual
orientation yeah we will be returning to
this but let's say that when i said in
the main part of the podcast that we
were failing children on many fronts
this is
uh
one of the most important and
people who think that this is some minor
fringe weird thing ought to rethink it
because this is
heading at civilization like a freight
train and of course our most fundamental
obligation is to protect children from
predatory adults we do a terrible job of
this it's not just pedophiles we also
don't manage to protect our children
from corporations that study their
behavior and sell them things that are
bad for them and all of that so this is
we have a long history of failing
children in this regard but we're about
to fail them at a new level and it must
not be allowed to happen
uh so
i recommend this zach if you would show
my screen our our friend uh who goes by
holly mathnerd
uh recently published this on her sub
stack on the push to destigmatize evil
why pedophilia must never be normalized
it's a incredibly difficult essay and
she gives plenty of trigger warnings
like which you should take seriously
yeah this this essay
should be read by many people as many
people as possible but it's not that it
should be read by everybody and so
please those warnings are not pro forma
please take them seriously and if you're
not somebody who should read it
don't yep
um but it uh
it
addresses several of the issues raised
by the person asking the
question yep
[Music]